الوضع طبعا الانساني صعب جدا كما تتخيلون
وكما تشاهدون ولكن المخزون على وشك انك
يعني حضرت المدير الاقليميه للبرنامج من
ان البرنامج الاقليمي برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه الان قد وزع بشمال غربي سوريا 25
الف حصه غذائيه تكفي عفوا حصص غذائيه تكفي
لاسبوع ل 25 الف شخص في مخازن برنامج
شركاء برنامج الاغذيه العالميه هناك حصص
غذائيه الان تكفي لمئه الف شخص ولكن هناك
حاجه ماسه الى تسهيل عبور المساعدات
الانسانيه الى المناطق المتضرره في كل
سوريا خاصه في الشمال السوري وهي المناطق
الاكثر تضررا برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
لانه يعمل في سوريا
ويعني يساعد سته ملايين شخص كل شهر حتى
قبل قبل
الكارثه يعني هناك حاجه ماسه الى
فتح كل وسائل الدخول الى شمال سوريا سواء
كانت عن طريق الداخل السوري او كل المعابر
انتم انتم كيف كيف توصلون المساعدات ايضا
الغذائيه الى هذه المناطق المتضرره خصوصا
في الشمال السوري والشمال الغربي من اي
معابر انتم دخلتم بهذه المساعدات
المساعدات تصل من الداخل السوري وايضا تصل
عن طريق معبر باب الهوى المعبر الوحيد
الذي يمكن الدخول منه الى الشمال السوري
عن طريق تركيا كان هناك معابر اخرى ولكن
تم غلقها لذلك يعني هناك حاجه ماسه الان
الى فتح كل هذه المعابر وايضا زياده
استيعاب
المنافذ من الداخل السوري حتى يستطيع
البرنامج ايصال مساعداته من جميع الجهات
هل تواصلتم مع اي
يعني باحد في سوريا مع نظام السوري مثلا
لمحاوله او طلب تسهيل هذه
المساعدات ودخول هذه المساعدات من الداخل
السوري الى المناطق المتضرره في الشمال
الغربي السوري
هو برنامج الفعل يعمل في سوريا نحن يعني
نحن ننسق مع جميع الاطراف للوصول الى
الاشخاص المتضررين برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه يهدف الوصول الى
كل الاشخاص الذين تضرروا من هذه الازمه
حتى الان وصلنا الى 43 الف شخص منهم
25,000 شخص في مناطق شمال غربي السوريه
ولكن يجب ان نستمر في التوزيع يجب ان يتم
تسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه او ازاله
العقبات اذا كانت موجوده يعني على لسان
المتحدث او المدير الاقليمي للبرنامج في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا قال بان هناك
حاجه الى تجديد هذا المخزون سيده ريم
وبالتالي نسال هنا عن كميه هذا المخزون
كيف ايضا ستتم اليه دخولها الى هذه
المناطق المتضرره وهل نتوقعها قريبا تاخذ
مزيدا من الوقت 90% من السكان في هذه
المناطق يعتمدون على مساعداتكم في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط نعم
ثلاثه اكثر شخص في هذه المنطقه ولذلك هناك
مخزون لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه هناك
مخزون يكفي لمئه الف شخص وجبات
لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع وهناك
مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف
شخص ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه ولكن تحتاج
الى طه بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات نحن
نستخدم ممر باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر
في داخل سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب
الزلزال والدمار
الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطئ لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات الانسانيه ولكن تم غلق
هناك 14 قافله ايضا حتى مساعدات واغاثه
ايضا دخلت مع معبر باب الهوى وقبل قليل
يعني كنت اسال احد الصحفيين موجودين في
اول بالقرب من معبر باب الهوى ذكر بان هذا
المعبر معبر مفتوح تدخل من خلاله ايضا
الشاحنات المساعدات الغازيه والانسانيه
وبالتالي لا يوجد في هذا المعبر اي ضرر
كبير يمنع المساعدات من الدخول عبره فهل
هناك تحديات وعوائق اخرى غير هذا السبب
هي فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب الدمار في
المنطقه نحن نتحدث هذه هي المنطقه التي هي
الاقرب لمركز الزلزال لذلك هناك بطء هناك
ايضا
[موسيقى]
تسارع الوصول الى هذه المنطقه مما يبتاء
عمليه الدخول ولكن حتى الان هناك
مساعدات يتم توزيعها يتم توزيعها منذ امس
كما ذكرت ل 25000 شخص هناك مخزونيه في 100
الف شخص ولكن نحن
نعمل على
انعاش هذا المقصود طيب يعني نحن نتحدث عن
عن مخزون يكفي لمده لمده اسبوع من المفترض
ان تصل مساعداتكم ان يتم تجديد هذا
المخزون قبل انتهاء هذا الاسبوع سيدريم هل
هذا ما افهمه
في غضون الايام القليله
فهو يعني ينفذ المخزون ما الذي سيساعدكم
على تعزيز قدرتكم في الوصول الى الشمال
شمال الغربي في سوريا
ما الذي سيسهل عملكم
وسيوصل هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل
المعابر تتحدثين عن باب الهوى عبر الراعي
وباب السلام